Speaker 1: Hey, this is a pretty big
deal. Former Attorney General Eric Holder
is now predicting that Donald Trump and his
top administration officials will be indicted,
will be indicted. Newsweek writes Former Attorney
General Eric Holder predicted Friday that Trump,
as well as other top officials from the former
president's administration, will be invited by the
indicted by the U.S. government over the events of
January six, 2021, and their efforts to change the
2020 results. In early May, Holder told CBS News
he believed Trump's actions related to January
six merit an indictment. Hundreds of Trump
supporters attacked the U.S. Capitol that day
after the then president told them to walk to the
federal legislative building and fight like hell
to save their country. Those directions came
after Trump claimed for months that Biden's
victory was fraudulent while pressuring officials
across the country to overturn the win. On Friday,
in an interview on HBO's Real Time with
Bill Maher, Holder reiterated his view
that Trump should face indictment. Let's take
a look at this video of Eric Holder explaining
this here to Bill Maher on his show Friday.
Speaker 2: If you were still the attorney
general about Trump and January six, well, I'll
tell you, if you'd asked me that question about a
year or so ago, I would have said I. Been awfully
concerned about the divisive nature of bringing a
case against a former president. But now, because
of what we know, what great journalists have done,
the leaks that have come from the January six
committee, if you show me that Donald Trump was
involved in the efforts to, in essence, foment
a coup, and you can show the requisite intent,
he has to be indicted.
Unidentified:
And what would that entail after you indict him?
After you indict him? Well, he would.
Speaker 2: Then, you know, you take him to trial
just like anybody else. I think, you know, you
can look at what Merrick Garland is going to do.
I think my primary, my first analysis
would be what's going to happen to him
in Georgia. Right. We've got him on tape saying,
you find me 11,783 is close to a layup, it seems
to me. I've always said the same thing about that.
Why don't they just go after that one moment. It's
on tape. You have the smoking gun, he's saying. I
mean, I remember when Rod Blagojevich was on tape,
basically, it didn't work out too well for him.
No, I know. But but it was it was it was it was
pretty blatant, but it wasn't as bad as find me
11,000 votes. Yeah. Yeah. No, I think as I said,
I think that's close to a layup. The D.A.
down there is going to be calling witnesses,
I understand, before a special grand jury.
But the interesting thing there is that that
can also be a specification and a federal
charge that could be brought in Washington,
D.C. When you're charging him with conspiracy to
defraud and conspiracy to obstruct, what happened
in Georgia can actually be part of a federal case
as well. So I think, you know, I was a federal
prosecutor doing political corruption cases when I
first came to the Justice Department for 12 years.
And you get a feel for these things after a while.
I get the feeling that I can see where this one is
going. And a lot of my level people in the Trump
administration, I suspect the president himself,
people at the Justice Department are all going
to find themselves on a little document that
says the United States versus fill in the body.
Speaker 1: So there is the prediction and the hope
would be that the Department of Justice will view
the upcoming January 6th hearings, which start
later this week as a way to say, well, now we
see it all in detail. And while the main purpose
of the January six committee is not criminal
investigation, if they uncover we've talked
about this before, if they uncover cover criminal
activity, they refer to the Justice Department to
look at it. And what Eric Holder is saying is how
that how could they come to any other conclusion?
Now, there are some who will say the hearings are
sort of embarrassing enough that you don't need
to indict. That's like the prototypical Susan
Collins thing. Republican Senator Susan Collins
loves to say, well, I was very disappointed
that they incited the riotous insurrection,
but the hearings were embarrassing enough
to them. And that's enough punishment. We
don't need to make this a political show trial.
I'm sure they would never do it again. They've
learned their lesson. That's the Susan Collins
approach. You'll probably hear that from some
in the coming weeks after we see what the January
six committee has, which will be fascinating to
see. We'll have these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.